hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to bendy and the dark
Revival I just got done running away
from something terrible that never
actually was a wait a minute
did you find them yet
are you kidding me
but I was so done with this so long ago
I was gonna beat the crap out of you
all right well
originally I did that in a much more
humane way but apparently I wasn't gonna
do that I already know about this I
already know about that I already know
about all this I'm back here now or
wherever the hell this is
I think it's back here no this is a new
area
I don't know where I am
huh oh
ah
well that's nice you know that's a movie
projector you'd think that it would be
moving images but it's apparently not
at least I have a shadow and my head
isn't missing like last time
okay so now that we got done with all of
that that means that we can continue on
and do whatever the hell we were doing
before
what that is I don't really know
you can only watch the same day in
cartoon so many times before you go
crazy I'm starting to forget what it was
they wanted me to change good thing I
take notes and what's with them little
numbers in the corner of the screen is
that some kind of code I better check
with the storyboard room is it a code
I don't know if it's code it's one two
three
that really
I did
okay that's what I thought it better not
have been that easy because if it was
that easy I was going to be very upset
yeah
so there's got to be another code I mean
that that definitely is a hint but
there's definitely got to be a code
somewhere in other pieces of Art
now what they are I don't really know
hello
okay
hmm
sure I'm getting a lot of bad was that a
gent card
oh you're standing in our world famous
screening room consider yourselves lucky
because not everyone gets to see in here
this room is where we watch our
in-progress animations at the end of
each day to see how they're coming along
inside the screening room you'll see a
door to the rider's hallway that's where
our writers and concept men and women
are working on our next Big Ideas back
there is two secret to show off but you
can use your imagination to picture what
might be in there
oh picture what might be in there I'm
sure a bunch of extremely hot oh
interesting
ah interesting okay so obviously this is
an in sequential order
so you gotta find the flower
you gotta pick the flower and then you
gotta run away from the B so three two
one would be the real code if you think
about it
no okay maybe not so the real code has
got to be
oh you find the flower first it's four
three
two
It's gotta be four three two
okay maybe not all right
first entered this world it was an
untamed wilderness
a wretched crawling slum
s ruled by that grinning
from chaos I brought order from order I
brought peace
once you got
from the snake
the snake bleeds out quietly onto the
ground
wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute okay you can't just pull a
fast one on everyone here
that was completely unnecessary why the
hell did you think that that was cool
because it was not okay so there's got
to be something else about these there's
got to be a clue right wait wasn't there
another projector over here
oh right
right
so picking looking running picking
looking running picking
oh oh
then running It's gotta be two on Five
excuse me you tell me that this ain't
correct what this is doing
look pick oh wait look down that's what
I meant by looking pick look down
I know what I'm talking about all the
time right two three five is what I
actually meant to say uh
[Music]
there we go there we go
there he is all right
come say hello why but I don't wanna hi
hello how are you
she was the fourth oh
bendy Alice and Boris it just works
workers my design for a new fourth
member of the butcher gang you can
almost hear the disgust at the lunch
table
ghost girl they said No One's Gonna Get
It
they just laughed at my drawings a
couple of them up like trash
but I'll get Mr true on my side he'll
understand
he's got to
Carly whale joined the butcher gang
and she'll be beloved by all
one way or another
called bringing currently to life
okay Jane I wonder what's in here I'll
just rip it open face first come
straight into my open arms and now I
look what's inside
well this is a little disappointing I
thought you were going to be a bit
different take that and one of those oh
one of these
all right I'm gonna turn my back to you
well that's probably not going to be a
problem
I hope that doesn't come back to
whoa I missed it God I'm
I'm do it again
I'm sorry guys I really love that one
man I couldn't have flubbed that any
harder huh I bet they really were I bet
so many people were like waiting for me
to get that particular scare right there
and man what did I do clubbed all over
it all right fine what am I supposed to
do I don't know what's happening here
this uh security lock doesn't seem to be
working so uh
hop in the trash Where I Belong I guess
um was there a key or something or uh
ahoozies and a scoozies anybody seen
some Oozy woozies what do I do
[Music]
what do I do what do I do what do I do
what do I do what do I do
there's a switch there I see a switch
answer me
we said one now
oh holy crap holy crap what the hell
were you
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop
sign
arts gate picture
as of nine o'clock this morning bendy
and all his little cartoon friends now
belong to me
strange owning a dear friend's Legacy
I think Joy would be
weaken safely in my hands
in such a Showman
well I believe Joey I wholeheartedly
believe
yeah I believe too I believe that
something's going on and something is uh
creeping after me I don't know why
I think they were mad that I missed the
jump scare but I'll just carry on and
scarf down whatever hello
hi Boris
is this symbolic is this symbolock
is this symbolism
all right whatever
maybe I'll meet Boris once again I sure
do miss him I miss him dearly and also
they've been giving me so many supplies
and yet nothing to do with them
you know I thought I thought with all
these things that I've been getting that
I would have had some way to spend them
high oh
give me your teleporting ability I can
already sense with my gamer of the Year
instincts and I'm going to steal that
from you I'll rip the powers right out
of your bones why don't you give it to
me now and then you would own well now
we won't have to sufferers much later oh
You're Gonna Wanna Rock
anyway I'm on the way now
oh
this is illogical
who built
yes
why would that be a thing
but what if oh you cowards you cowards
you cowards don't hide anything up there
you cowards oh I flipped the switch and
then I go up and then I go in that tube
and there was a secret item in there but
it could kill me if I don't get on oh
you cowards
cowards
thank you thank you
words all right thank you
I guess I'm not going back then
well it's a good thing I did everything
that I needed to do before the machine
must endure must it
mustard
I have please okay thank you
in no not in seems like in I want to go
in the tube I could have gone in the
tube how could you not let me go in the
tube
where else would I belong but in the
tube give me your powers
are you looking for the way out yes
are you
stuck in there
oh well yes and I'm afraid that means
well
you're stuck too can't you move not an
inch
perhaps you could get me unstuck I'll
see what I can do
I am going to slurp the powers
straight out of you I'm gonna slurp them
right out of you I'm hoping this slurps
the powers right now take my strong hand
huh well I wasn't intending to do that
but I'll follow after you because I
still need to slurp your powers right
out of you Porter
yeah I'm sure I'm fine you know I was
supposed to be going up I remember the
advice that I was going up the name's
Porter by the way
who might you be
Audrey Audrey Audrey Audrey
nope it looked like it doesn't suit you
I'll call you Bobby huh and to say
thanks for your feet of rescue here's a
little gift
something I learned
[Music]
there we are
passed on
now you can move like me
thanks Bobby
I appreciate it Bobo
thanks Bobby
oh you too Bobby
all right take care Bob
all right anyway now I can do that one
I really would have rather slurped it
right out of his bones but whatever all
right would use flow I'm flowing oh I
flowed
I don't know what all the residual flow
is all about but I flowed
hey I'm back here
wow
I'm back here
wow oh wait no it's not it's on cooldown
all right well hey everybody else you're
gonna be really happy with me whoever is
here anybody still here anybody anybody
still here anybody I was supposed to go
up but then I didn't oh yeah
anyway I got that got the sickest flow
hey hey hey hey hey hey
watch out for my flow
you okay there
I flow
what are you doing over there
what are you doing
you going into the employee Locker huh
well you're about to go
[Music]
all right
get something in your throat dude
you might wanna
Hawk it up
just letting you know
oh man
I can't believe I am forced to search
every single one of these lockers which
I am because they put them here and
therefore because they're openable and
they might have something my gamer
instincts tells me to open every single
one of them
this is your fault game developers you
didn't give me a tube to climb up but
you gave me a million lockers open it's
your fault
damn them
who does this who could do this
who would dare do this
don't get me wrong we've always had
visitors around the studio
which
giant Corporation employees tons of them
they're working in the hallways ripping
off the floors taking the best toilets
level Lounge these days
feel less like an anime
more and more like some crazy scientists
Laboratory
it's just plain weirdness
yeah it's just plain weirdness yeah it
ain't never seen nothing like it people
in suits telling us animators what does
dos and whatnots I don't likes it it
ain't for me's and it definitely ain't
for these and that is
God damn they put too many lockers here
damn them to Hell there's so many lovers
five
what do you mean you put an essential
code for progress in there
did you do this who did this man this
might be the most pathetic thing I've
ever complained about but I am
complaining about it and I'm standing by
my complanations so if anyone complains
about my complications then they're
they're just adding to the pile of
complaints so their complaints are
entirely invalid because if they're
complaining about something that I'm
complaining about they're only adding to
the net amount of complaints that are in
the universe and it's their fault and
not mine that the complaints are rising
I know I already got the code but
there's still more lockers so of course
I have to open them
[Music]
okay
I don't care
I wasted too much time opening lockers
you think I can spend time looking at a
note how would anybody even have time
for that
or something
I don't even know what it was
hello gen upgrades what is this
[Music]
okay
what
[Music]
what do you mean what did I just do to
this thing what did I do who did I do
where did I do I don't know what I did
what is this doing what am I doing what
am I doing
what did I do
access to secure places now granted when
your gent pipe is charged you can spend
its power on opening gen locks around
the studio what's behind them only a
bravest will seek them out for their
rewards
who told me that what voice in my head
just said that how would I even known
that hey good thing that they gave you
exactly the amount of materials that you
wouldn't need to be able to do this in
the first place
that was awfully nice of them
almost made all my farming and get
things
do I have to go charge this again now
yeah it is
what I gotta do huh
do I gotta go I gotta go charge this up
again because I just I just blew the
charge all over the place so I might as
well charge her up
is that what I gotta do huh
all right fine I did it I don't even
know how to read the charge oh I see the
charge on it okay but you just lock that
up because you just needed to
tutorialize
[Music]
that guy die
yes yes to you yes
[Music]
come on death death to my enemies
pain and suffering no I just
Bane you will know pain
[Music]
to the depths of Eternal suffering for
you and all your kind
pay a box
nice bacon soup I love that
that's some good stuff
all right well this was a fun area I
guess that's the guy that went to the
bathroom and now he's dead
I'm what they crawl I spun around for
some reason don't know why
I tried looking over there as well
I don't know why anyway are you ready
for
Eternal damnation checklist
you will never survive the onslaught I
will make sure your family never sees
you again
okay they're all dead now and I didn't
even have to use my flow
unlocked
[Music]
man I'm so glad that I upgraded this
wrench because it does so much more
damage to everybody the keepers see
everything the keepers see my ass
I almost I was not ready my flow
all right let's try that again
did I hear someone's voice
should I use this again
oh so this one stays open you'll see
that the other one didn't stay open you
know my flow
anybody seen my flow
anybody I want a piece of my flow
[Music]
well or I have been inflicting pain on
others and uh you really should stop
smoking it is doing something horrible
to your voice
but also no no
I'm trying
Hey look it's another way out welcome to
artist rest
they give them beds
oh blankets and hot coffee oh that's so
nice
oh it's like a tube or a coffin
you know honestly I know that there are
hotels like this I really want to try
one of them someday
because I'm super down
to sleep in like a very confined space
I'm not ordinarily claustrophobic but I
I'm not of the point that I like in
close spaces like I'm probably the
normal amount of claustrophobic that
everybody is but something about being
in like a really really enclosed space
just it's very comforting when I was on
tour
and we were sleeping on the tour bus I
slept like a baby every night I slept so
good I slept just like it was a dream
it was so nice to be able to do that who
do you think you are not me not ever me
never be me
stop trying to pee me
well you're dead now so you can leave
yourself alone I will let you endlessly
feel my wrath okay you hurt a lot my
flow
[Applause]
where did where did you what happened
I don't know what just happened
[Music]
is there any coffee in there or there
was hot coffee in here
well
oh
I see I'll go to the sauna then dude
don't mind me don't mind me it's a sauna
sauna uh I'm reading you can't attack me
we don't live forever when we're killed
or finally pulled apart our diseased
Souls return to the ink to be reborn an
endless cycle of Torment but sometimes
something even worse can happen a soul
can slip from the end completely it gets
caught between worlds unable to die or
return they wail in the night drifting
in Shadow the Phantoms of the machine
the ghosts here it goes
my flow
well I'm almost dead
man I don't want to sleep in that room
watch out for my flow I can't run oh man
I'm real slow right now wow
well
your mistake was not finishing me
when you had the chance
I think though like in Japan they have
those but I'm pretty sure they've got to
have these like around everywhere
foreign they've got to have them around
everywhere right
it can't just be
it can't just be in Japan so there's got
to be other places for them I just don't
know where they would be
um oh gent upgrades you say
huh
it gotta be food I know there's got to
be like a
foodie dispenser
just for us employees
every night when you add in the traffic
and the waiting pretty elevators you
practically only have a few hours before
you have to wake up and come back
so Joe we had them built our distressed
for us now we never have to leave work
again Joey says
well elephant it's become wipe the
hangout spot down here almost like it's
a whole little District
but there's definitely some unsavory
stuff going on too
there's a lot of noise around here
well damn sorry everybody's having so
much fun
sorry the smoking and or the gambling is
getting you a down at night
oh flow flow
that's good flow I need some health real
bad I've been kind of fighting everybody
I don't mind if I do what is it a
schematic for who knows but here we go
high impact mod how do I not have any of
these
how do I not have any of these how do I
not have any of that no well I'll get it
later
am I supposed to high impact this door
is that what I was supposed to do it
seems like there's a severe lacking of
those uh dual pouch parts and it's not
like I can craft anything because that's
not what the crafting's about in this
game apparently
well
time to eat the old dusty drill upper
beds let's try the upper beds wait what
was over here anyway can I go over here
in the ZZ here oh
yes please oh my God oh my God
all right I'm ready to Wallop the [ __ ]
out of anybody
just try to gamble and smoke in my
vicinity oh I'm gonna wallopize you
I'm gonna is there someone about to be
wallopy you you missed me stupid
all right well there's one more I need
many many more of those things and it's
fascinating that I haven't found enough
given that I've looked in absolutely
every nook and or cranny in this place
there's an area cranny that I haven't
looked in
let me look in your cranny
miss me dust I want to kiss me hmm
[Music]
well now I know how to beat him you
sidestep him
hostile controls
I put the crane in the lost and found
office some dope keeps leaving them out
while I tried to get in the lost and
found office I didn't I didn't I wasn't
able to I didn't
I didn't do well no I can't do that I
have three of those I don't need more I
need to get in the lost and found office
but I don't have enough to do that
uh-huh
well try again maybe I must have missed
a key or something I don't know also it
seems very strange that the Central
Command like uh has access to open these
doors like this is very strange
is there a key in here that I missed
anybody seen a key or is it here and I I
don't have the ability to go in there
well that's a dick and a half
yeah that that right there's the oh ah
that was easy to miss
huh I've only had a master key hello
anybody want to see my flow oh
I should be uh worried I'm worried I'm
worried I'm worried my flow haha fool
you don't have flow you don't have any
flow
you're Flawless that's what you are
that's right stomp away man he stumped
away fast he must have been terrified of
me
yeah probably to go out for a smoke
break
all right I got the key for the Hoist
hi Wilson
[Music]
so don't be afraid
your favorites
okay Wilson
um I don't really have any confidence in
your ability to do anything so
I don't know of what you're referring to
what was this for hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey
thanks for the sandwich what was that
what did I do I don't even know what I
did my flow ah [ __ ]
how about this my flow
snakeball hurt me super bad
ouch
hey uh can I get some more of the food
hi what are you doing the food's for me
that's right I'll take your sandwich
okay I guess I'm done
so yeah what did that do I wasn't
looking because I got attacked by
literally everything
so tell me what it did what happened to
it do I need to jump out onto it no
[ __ ]
um
all right
that was a close one
um maybe I need to bring it back or
something if I nope okay uh maybe I
um
I don't know what that's about
so yeah upper beds is now open I just
gotta get over there so I may be able to
jump from there over to the balcony
there
but how do I get over there
right I can flow
oh oh I'm so dumb
wow I'm so dumb
okay oops I'm extremely
my flow
I can't believe
after I've been yammering on about it
that I forgot about my flow so how do I
make sure that I get where I need to go
I think I gotta float there right maybe
you want to get up here it won't let me
there's an invisible wall there
okay
well it does say flow there
does say but this is open
but that's there
but this is now open I want to go here
hello
this looks important
and wow
perfect
I'm much shinier permanently upgrade
your ability cooled I'll better flow
hell yeah
hell yeah better flow okay good thing I
went there first it's really hard to
tell what what I'm actually supposed to
go to first I have no idea though okay
but now I should be able to flow this
way and then I'll get out of here
good thing it didn't look like I was
lost forever and that lexian did such a
goddamn amazing job at making this all
perfect for me thanks lyxian you're the
best I appreciate you
feeling something pulling in my mind
my thoughts
we opened last week
outside one or two of the artists I
don't think I've ever seen a single soul
go inside that's a shame how so many of
us refuse to learn
the past give us our greatest lessons
but still ever since we moved enjoys old
things
between The Reeling around Art's gate
like the coasts of long ago
wandering about
calling out to me
the ghosts have long about eh it
couldn't be this magical ink machine
that you use to capture the souls of all
your employees and Infuse them into the
arts history that you have made and
presented to the world you didn't notice
the ink dripping down the Walls
reminiscent of at a building full of
blood of sorts no of course not of
course not of course not
man I feel like they gave me too many
batteries I feel like I have an
excessive number of batteries
the machine must endure sure
and I'm [ __ ] did you just call me [ __ ]
I'm Joey Drew and yours [ __ ] I've never
been more insulted in my life ah that
hurt I hurt my feelings between us I
will
uh no we're in and out like rats
scurrying all over the place people
shoving and pushing the way this
elevator system is set up you'd think we
had only 10 employees working here at
any time of the day this Hall is full of
people waiting to go up right around
quitting time you're gonna have to grab
a magazine and wait your turn it just
goes to show that Joey Drew Studios
really did grow too much too fast but I
hear there's more than one way to escape
this rats maze I'm gonna do some asking
around here man that would be awful I'll
be horrible that would be horrible
I don't particularly like elevators too
much but man I can't even imagine trying
to wait for one
in a line I mean oh
Wham where am I
where am I
I'm opening this
hello
anything important in here there better
be
there better be some of those duel kits
that's all I got to say about that
there's one I need like 12 of them and
more batteries why do I need so many
batteries Joey Drew why do I need so
many batteries
he better let me actually get all this
there we go see I'm fine with that I'm
fine with that you actually let me get
the things that I needed again not
closing my face that was very rude when
you did it before I'm gonna go charge up
my stick again because why not you know
I didn't even have to craft the cars
they just gave the cards to me I don't
even know why I needed them
I mean I know why I need them because I
need more stuff and I might have the
stuff that I need if it would have given
me the stuff that I needed before but it
just gave me the cards without even the
the preconceived notion of having to
craft them
fine by me I guess can I flow over there
can I flow no I can't
go around
no I couldn't possibly open that from
this side what is who is tanning leather
over there
who's doing that also where am I
supposed to go
oh can I open it again
damn
it just has stuff in here
so uh
so what about that oh
I'm over the cart
I'm over the cart and move it a car okay
and that was some good car moving that
was good car moving okay so I have one
more card I have three 23 batteries
I have 23 batteries
I mean if it'll let me open the thing
again I'll use my other card why why
keep them right
well these aren't the things that I need
are they
who needs slugs
who needs them who needs slugs in any
way it probably takes those uh it takes
two of these I need two of those top
grades my whacker all right whatever
yeah who is uh who is um
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
okay
see what I don't realize is why did he
close the door before coming after me it
feel like it was inefficient to his
pursuit of me I feel like if he really
wanted to destroy me and decimate me and
Rend my bones then he wouldn't have
closed the door
but that's just me I'm an idiot so what
do I really know
over here now that you're not here over
here definitely not Wham
uh-huh man a lot of food
only add more supplies hello you okay
all right
bumpity Daisy
Lacey and can you like entertain him for
a bit um
this elevator is a lot longer than I
thought just you okay all right you're
done good good good thank you thank you
thank you for that
no actually listen come back out you
gotta entertain him
still working on it
[Music]
[Music]
what
manual what
[Music]
thank you
no
Lucy and bring it back out the
entertainment uh we're gonna oh never
mind never mind never mind never mind
save it we gotta exit
we have head crabs no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no kill it
with fire no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no
no
I'm beginning to think that I'm supposed
to be running away
oh coffee
wait 15 slots 50
. what
what Hope phone no I'm I'm I'm I'm a
reasonable guy I'll pay a good amount of
money for a good cup of coffee there
ain't no way in no kind of hell that in
this era in this time I don't care what
kind of Monopoly ass Joey Drew dollars
you got here I ain't paying 15 bucks for
a cup of coffee and I will take that to
the bank because I ain't going on
anymore and I'm gonna not save because
I'm unloading this [ __ ] and I'm going
back and losing that progress because
I'm not gonna pay 15 bucks for a cup of
coffee I don't care if I'm mid combat I
don't care if I'm about to die death is
meaningless when we're all part of the
ink okay no 15 coffee no one should
stand for that and I expect everyone to
do the same you don't let that stand you
don't let that slide you stop everything
and you question that if someone's like
I don't care if you're at the counter
they got the cup of coffee for you and
they're like you're got your card here
and you're about to slamming in the
machine they say that'll be 15 bucks you
hold everything you stop you push that
cup of coffee right back onto not onto
them but back uh oh across the counter
you say have a good day I don't want to
be ever here again and then you leave
and then that's what I'm gonna do and
I'll come back when they're more
reasonable about their coffee prices
thank you everybody so much for watching
as always I'll see you in the next one
bye-bye
[Music]